[Music]
hello everyone this is how to become a
grand master I'm Dennis Bosch and today
we're going to do something unusual
usually I take a look at
people who become Grand Masters and how
did they become Grandmasters but this
time it's going to be different this
time it's good it's going to be the
pupil and the coach himself now the
person of interest in this topic is
Vincent kymer or Kamer kymer thank you
very climber and he is one of the newest
2700 players now there have been a big
boom in chess especially in India with
gukesh pragnananda and many others
joining the high ranks and reaching 2700
plus but Europe used to be the one
carrying the torch and the newest
edition of a 2700 is Vincent kymer and
he of course is coached by none other
than the legendary Hungarian the
championship Challenger Peter laco
so we are going to start off with a
couple of his games and then
transitioned to Vincent's game now Lego
is very well known for his subtle
slow-moving style kind of like an
anaconda so we're going to actually see
that in action in these couple of games
so this is a Lego short
E4 now how times are changing E4 used to
be exquisitely the only move played on
top level and was the most popular move
but since then as you're going to see in
Vincent's game he will not play one E4
which was very popular I mean for many
reasons but mostly because of Bobby
Fischer
so E4
E5 topical at those times in the 90s and
the late 90s but still kind of the hype
today before E5 the most solid approach
you can have that F3 Knight C6 Bishop B5
and this is actually the critical move
they've been people Mouse slipping and
play the Italian but all the ogs of the
Chess World know that the Spanish is the
big and more aggressive way of playing
is you are putting some pressure on the
E5 Pawn A6 should pay four man of six
castles rookie one D6 now leco is very
well known to be a big theoretician even
in those days they thought that he knows
a lot so here Nigel short avoids his Pat
Marshall which of course happens after
B5 Bishop B3 castles and has been
debated since with pretty good results
for black in fact Magnus calls and
defended his title based on their
Marshall Gambit versus karyakan
so short goes for D6 and this is the
first moment I am going to stop and ask
the chat and everyone on YouTube what
you think about this position
now D6 of course is not a mistake
although a sideline it over defends the
E5 Pawn however it does allow a couple
of ideas for white
now whenever you look at a position you
should always look first at potential
threats by your opponent so what could
be sense what sort of danger might be
lurking in this position for white
how to get become a grand master study
study study I mean it's also good
to look at a lecture or participate in a
lecture if you participate you may not
get the answers right but at least you
try
Lego was the god of his time yeah he was
very close to becoming a world champion
and in fact narrowly missed out of
becoming a world champion himself
yeah the thread over here is going to be
five Bishop B3 and Knight A5
now when Nigel short plays D6 it's a
very very normal move but it does allow
something that wouldn't happen and
wouldn't work otherwise
Bishop b395 is his threat and in that
case our Bishop would be trapped over
there
the problem with that and just to
demonstrate H3 B5 Knight A5 the bishop
gets trapped and you really don't get
too much for it you mostly are just down
the bishop there
so why its goal in this position is a
either to avoid that or somehow take
advantage of the fact that black did not
commit with the idea of Pawn to B5
and here Lego's choice is somewhat
surprising on the other hand not at all
a bad choice
he decides to take on C6
and taking on C6 may look weird I mean
you might be asking well didn't you tell
me that we're supposed to keep the
bishop well he exchanges this bishop for
the reason that it will lead to a
doubled Pawn on this side of the board
and he's going to take advantage of that
goes D4
and tries to undermine the center note
that Nigel's King is still on E8 and is
actually prone to be attacked if he's
not careful so that safe captures
captures C5 would be unfortunate Knight
C6 and already there are some threats
around Black's King and of course the
queen is under attack immediately
now Nigel avoids that plays Knight to D7
so there is actually a famous talk and a
compensation between Yasir saravan and
Victoria Fortune
Yasser famously asked well isn't that
pawn a weakness and Court schnoy replied
well it's only a weakness if you are
able to attack it
so our goal in this position is a to
find a way to get close to the C Pawn or
B to create more weaknesses in Short's
position
because for the moment black is holding
up perfectly well he has the Bishops
there's no sign of those pawns falling
ever so quickly
so our goal should be to somehow sort of
either improve our situation or B try to
create even more weaknesses in Black's
camp
how could we go about that
and again to refer back to a chat
message there of course studying is very
important but using your own brain and
trying to figure out a position and in
fact just
providing your own two cents of what
you're thinking about the position is
very important
the worst thing you can do is sort of
rely on anything else you are supposed
to find a way of getting closer try to
get close to solution in the position it
may not be correct but at least trying
is the first step
so we already mentioned the C Pawn is
potentially the big Target in the
position
how could we get close to that one
you could take on E5 and get the Knight
to C4 very good Simon very good idea you
are creating a weakness on E5
and as that pawn can move away because
it's fixed by my e-pawn you will have
the time to go on id2 Knight C4 you
wouldn't want to go an id2 immediately
because if black castles
Knight C4 I can't capture on D4 takes I
will just defend this Pawn
and black is more or less fine although
it's still kind of awkward but probably
C5 still works
so D text C5 is a very smart choice
there
just fixing the pawn on a bad square and
then go after the pawn on E5
but we still haven't had an idea how to
go after the C Pawn so 92 and going
captures captures Knight C4 that's great
but how could we go after the c-pawn we
still haven't really figured that one
out
a lot of times it's good to sort of
gather ideas in a position
um
it doesn't mean that you're going to
play them but you know in the back of
your mind it's good to know what you're
aiming for
you can go Queen E2 and queen C4 exactly
you can go that way you can also go C3
Queen A4
although whenever you push your Pawn you
can never go backwards which is of
course a problem but of course we need
to Queen C4 makes sense as well
so Peter takes on E5
takes B3
so we looked at around two plants but he
comes up with the third so we talked
about Knight D2 Knight C4 talk about
Queen E2 Queen C4
haven't really thought about this move
of B3 now
every position
is about a balance
even though black has a doubled pawn and
weak pawns at that and a weak Pawn on E5
black has a trump card what is that
trump card in Black's position
that makes this whole setup viable for
short
what could it be
well it's the bishop pair
Mike has the bishop bear so this move of
Pawn to B3 actually responds to that
Lego is not in a rush to go after those
spawns he says those spawns are going to
stay there and you'll be able to go
after them but at this very moment I may
just be able to go Bishop A3 trade off
one of your Bishops you'll lose the
compensation and you are just saddled
with those pawns on c67 and E5
castles Bishop A3
very nice little move trading off that
active well not so active Bishop but it
actually may come active if you don't
pay attention to it like after Bishop C5
that Bishop is pretty good
so Lego circumvents that goes for Bishop
A3
F6
Queen D3
so he managed to go after the bishop on
E7 and he's combining two ideas he's
trading the Bishops and he's targeting
the C Pawn
I see Grand Masters analyze positions in
terms of ideas but practically one needs
consideration of different candidate
moves an exact calculation what kind of
training might help with that skill so
this is sort of lap you are supposed to
try to understand a position on your own
come to your own conclusions and then
compare that's how you actually improve
as a chess player
may it be if you're an international
Master to a grand master or a freedom
Master to an international Master it
really doesn't matter they're all
working with the same positions but if
you're using the right techniques you
should be able to improve your chess
game so here Lego sort of
answered the long strategical problem of
black having the bishop there and only
now he meant for the exact calculation
of going for the C Pawn
king queen C3
and today's chess players mostly think
about
calculating and calculating is important
but here in fact the long-term problems
and the long-term ideas are more of the
core importance in this position so the
fact that black is going to have to
defend those pawns forever because it's
very unlikely you'll be able to trade it
off because I will be always there to
guard that square
means that White's Advantage is
guaranteed then till the end of time
till the end of this chess game
and for that you don't need to calculate
you just need to understand the position
and one of those things that Lego does
extremely well is understanding The Core
Concepts in a chess position
today's chess player isn't as good at
understanding Core Concepts as they're
good at calculating and making sure what
they're looking at is perfect or what
calculations they had are to the point
so Bishop B7 Knight D2
so we see these moves but let's try to
make sense of it why do you think
laco decides to go and play Knight F to
D2 instead of the B1 Knight apart from
the apparent reason of trying to defend
that Bishop
of course that's one of the reasons but
you know
let's expect a little bit more
from Peter laco and we of course expect
more from him he definitely has more
reasons than that
I mean we're kind of doing that uh
vishwas we're trying to take a look at
why Lego makes the moves he does why he
goes Knight F to D2 when our natural
idea would be just to develop the pieces
especially because our Rook on A1 is
cramped on that square why would leiko
do that
and for you to understand
a higher level of Chess or a good level
of understanding or language chess in
general you have to ask these questions
hello
so there are a couple of key squares in
this position one of them is the C4
square but that's not the only one
chess is sort of a bad balances
Lego can sort of predict what short is
attempting to do what short is
attempting to do is to capture go Queen
E7 and just try to activate his pieces
so it would make no sense to capture on
E7 because in that case you're actually
improving and giving an extra tempo for
short
why King h8 Bishop B7 over C5
let me go back there
so there is the simple reason that Queen
D5 check wins darok
so C5 doesn't really work now
I just pick up the Rook
and if you go Bishop B7 you're always in
danger of getting checked and in fact uh
white candy use that with this move of
Rook to D1
if the Knight moves away then I have
Queen C4 check and then you're
struggling because you didn't hit your
king in due time
so King age it is a super Grand Master
prophylactic move making sure that the
king is tucked away and it there is no
sign of danger
as you can see three this should be
seven and the reason why laco doesn't go
Knight D2 here
it's because if you take take Knight D2
black actually manages to rewrite his
pieces accordingly
so
what do you think is the plan you for
sure that he would like to do also Paul
thank you for your message
the plenty of pieces that are awkward
the B7 bishop and the Knight on D7 is
very very awkward however
you may notice that this trade actually
facilitates one specific idea in this
position
that black cannot do in any other case
yeah it's the plan of Knight to C5
Knight D6 and once this Knight gets to
E6 the idea of pushing the C5 Pawn
actually gains strength you could go C5
but then you're sort of denying your own
Knight on D7 you really don't have more
than just an active Bishop you would
want to combine those two so you'd go
Knight to C5 let's say VOD gets this
juicy outpost on C4 and then black could
go some like Knight T6 C5 controlling
the D4 square and activating the bishop
I'm not saying that there are no
problems like here Knight A5 still looks
very very very nice for white however
it still gives a glimmer of hope for
short to consolidate
so it goes Knight F to D2 and you might
might see that after it captures you are
the one helping me develop because even
though Knight is on the side it will
land on an outpost shortly
it's going to land there it's going to
be very comfortable and I already
actually made a useful move it might be
able to go to E3 and even to have five
later on
and to F5
let me get my arrows straightened
and you actually lost the tempo there
so you can go C5
but then again you're kind of denying
your knight a good square and this
Knight is going to be really really bad
also white can also go Knight E5 putting
pressure on the bishop
so you go through ba Knight C4 and now
again we're sort of having this slow
maneuvering tug of war
white isn't going to Grant any easy
squares for the queen he says well if
you want to do something you may want to
capture here and help me develop if you
don't do it view that simply C5 again
well that will mean that you will have
two bad pieces
so oftentimes it's not really about
improving your own pieces but about
actually denying your opponent good
piece play
Bishop A8 and that buy in itself is not
a happy move
92. take six we need seven so you made
sense that black actually had to spend
extra moves uh until he could get his
Queen to E7 meanwhile Lego gained a lot
of time
Queen A5
all right
so it's time for us to evaluate The
Possession
who do you think is better what do you
think will be our long-term plan
as Peter laco
I mean I did give some subtle hints but
it's okay to use them up
if you listen you're just benefiting
from that
ideally fix the C6 Pawn okay but how
would you go about it
so it's great whenever we have an idea
what we want to achieve but it has to
materialize somehow
Paul was saying I think it's safe to say
that white is better has more active
nights over the stranded bishop and will
attack on the Queen's side yeah this
bishop on A8 is mummified over there on
that square it really can go out and if
you push the pawn it may even become
weaker
you've got this beautiful apples on C4
however truth be told we are still not
in a position to attack the C6 Pawn
I'm a little bit surprised that none of
you really mentioned that the A6 spawn
is hanging
I mean we can't really take it yet but
once we get the Knight on C4 it's going
to become a real threat and um that's
something that short will have to take
care of not to mention the C7 Pawn
so this move by Lego even though for the
moment is a ghost Strat
because
the Knight on A3 is a little loose but
once he gets the Knight to C4 these
become real
you can also get your knight to E3
exactly and you can also get and go to
F5 afterwards
it's Knight C5 over defending so now you
may have noticed I wasn't wrong Nigel is
trying to get his Knight to the juiciest
squares out there
and one of those other things that
modern players sometimes overlook the
center squares are still the golden
squares you may go after so like the D4
square is that
useful one because it already hits on C2
and it sort of restricts my split
goes Knight C4 Bishop B7
over defending but it's not a happy move
I mean short isn't making these moves of
back and forth because he's enjoying it
Queen A3
another little nasty pen you can't move
the Knight you don't have time to go
there I just take your queen
rookie eight Rook D1 Knight E6 all right
the big question
should we trade that clean or not
and these are Big questions
anytime you get a position of power so
you're the one calling the shots that
doesn't necessarily mean you don't have
to make decisions
right now
you have to decide whether a trade would
favor us or not
and of course it always has an upside
and a downside
so what do we think does this have more
upside to it or more downside
the queen might be an important piece
for our strategy we should prefer
keeping it okay
I like the queen trade since the minor
pieces are still around to attack the
weak Pawns
okay
all right so let's say we trade
what would be the ideal spots for the
knights that we have
what is the ideal scenario here
because yes our Knight on C4 is
beautiful but the Knight on D2 is sort
of helpless and it really doesn't do too
much
well C5 we can't really do because that
is actually controlled by black
well yes exactly
so the other night it may eventually get
to F5 and then we found two beautiful
apples for our Knights they're all
working
it's a beautiful work environment over
there
both Knights has a job to do
and the other thing is if we move our
Queen well
black would just continue on with his
plan of rolling with C5 and Knight D4
I'm not saying that moving the queen is
necessarily bad however
there is a natural flow to the position
so Queen E7 is very logical and if you
know
if you know Peter leco you know that he
actually likes these technical positions
Knight F1 and uh what actually Lego does
very well is harmony most of his pieces
are well harmonizing
in G8 Knight E3
and for Knight F5
King f8 Rook D2 so this is a threat but
he also wants to take control of the
only open file that you can have
C5 F3
over defending the structure
if our Knight eventually gets to F5 then
how can we judge the consequences of a
potential G6 push
okay so we are on consensus here that
white is better
however to win a chess game you will
either need to win material or create
weaknesses in Black's position
so let's say I go Knight F5
I provoke G6
we actually created a weakness in the
position
black already had two weaknesses on C7
and C5 very hard to get to but this is a
third weakness the rule of thumb is if
there are two weaknesses there's a good
chance of winning three well sign me up
that's great news
so
here what we're going to see from leco
is that he's going to slowly squeeze
this position where he clearly has the
advantage but it's not winning just yet
Rook d8 Rook takes Rook D1 so he is
always quick to trade off shorts good
pieces 96 985 again already pressing
that Defender because if this bishop is
gone I will have full control over the
D5 Square it should be eight
Knight F5 okay F7 King F2 so one move
forwards and one improving the position
again we'll move forward improving the
position
King E8 C3
G6 Knight T3 and sometimes we only
concentrate on our own moves but it's
actually a mistake
chess is a game for two players your
opponent is obliged to make a move
so oftentimes it's much worse to react
G6 here I feel might be more detrimental
to Short's position than not making any
Palm moves at all
H5
King E1 H4
so he's trying to clamp down Legos King
side however that H Pawn may even become
a weakness in the long term
Knight C4 Knight B2 Knight A4 incoming
let's see
so now G4 and this is the reason why
h5h4 is not necessarily a great move
because you do not have this move of H5
anymore kicking out the Knight
so making aggressive moves may be useful
if you're playing against an aggressive
opening because you have to punish it
somehow let's say the dragon or the
noidorf but in a subtle end game like
this pushing the pawns forwards
aggressively may actually backfire and
in this case now this Knight
cannot be removed it's an unmovable
Force that's very difficult to reckon
with
can you have fate King F2 G3 so Lego is
actually taking advantage of the fact
that the H Pawn is weak and may actually
use the H far to his own Advantage take
six
rookie seven King E3 not yet at least
Rook D2
Knight F2
so it's slowly improving the position
he didn't go Knight C4 Knight B2 Knight
A4 but he found another way and he's
actually going for Knight D3 Knight G4
Knight F2 and he is going for an ID3 and
attacking it that way he may even have
some time to go that direction but what
you should notice in these positions is
that these threats sometimes Force the
opponent to make an armed forced error
because it's very difficult just to wait
and see and just watch your opponent
actually circle around your weaknesses
F7 Knight D3 very very subtle and
beautiful technical play by Leica
Rogue D7 E3
preparing an eventual b42
B4 thanks thanks
King G7
so you might be wondering well wait a
second didn't you tell me that the C5
Pawn is going to be a weakness well yes
but Lego decides that in the long run
the a pawn is going to be a much easier
Target to latch onto
because you will have this idea of Rook
A2 Knight to B3 and Knight to C5 I'm
going to go after the a pawn and just
conjure it up it's much easier to attack
it than to attack the C5 Pawn
also this method of attack what laco is
using creates less weaknesses in his
Camp so there is no room for a counter
play
if you go Knight C4 Knight B2 Knight E4
you are actually loosening your grip on
the position
so Lake was trying to keep the grip on
the position making sure that Nigel
doesn't have any sort of counter play
and then he can go after the a pawn
without any problems okay too
Knight B3 and just as I said he's lining
up on and against the a-pop at C5
and it's basically winning the pawn
because it's a double attack so one of
the key piece whenever you're trying to
better your chest is to aim for double
attacks now whenever you're starting out
your journey as a beginner it's much
more difficult but if you practice them
if you practice the tactics of attacking
two pieces the same time or pieces and
Pawns I tell you honesty oftentimes they
win you material and it's the case here
as well
Bishop C8 now of course if you take that
doesn't change the situation because
Lego has another Knight that will double
attack you may be able to defend the
bishop but in that case I'm just winning
the A6 Pawn
I would have never thought to trade away
the C5 bonds as Paul
at some high level stuff yes this is um
very much in Peter laco's style he likes
playing in sort of restricting the
counter play of his opponent and um this
is actually very much in the old style
of capablanca and many other Legends
take stakes and bouquetics and that
gives the advantage
but Bishop C8 was played Knight takes A6
so the reason why
short goes for Bishop C8 he's trying to
keep up some pieces on the board so he
can use them later on and get some play
that's why he goes for F5 and that's
already desperation and it leaves the E
Pawn weak Knight C5 again laco is not
tempted to go for any free pawns he just
makes sure that the short spaces are
still bottled up
takes Pawn takes
Bishop G4 Knight D3 again cutting off
this Rook
rookie eight okay seven okay seven b
five
C4 slowly pushing the extra pawn and
it's almost game over Knight B4 and
short resigned because there is really
no way of avoiding that Knight D5
successfully even if you go Bishop E6
there's plentiful ways of winning you
can push the beep on but even Knight D5
leads to a winning rook and pawn ending
where just too many Pawns that short
cannot deal with so very very beautiful
technical
game by leco now I do want to show one
more
Lego brilliancy
and one from camera
so let's take a look this one is Peter
laco versus Pinter
uh pintara if you don't know him he's
been a Hungarian Champion a very very
strong player in his own right so this
is actually going to be a big fight E4
E5 not surprising even in the 90s before
E5 was a solid choice I mean
even earlier than that E4 E5 was all the
hype
Bishop B5 obviously the best move he
plays the Spanish
should be 7 B5 D6
just plays the slower version C3 cancels
HD so if you would go D4
the Natural Choice black and gold Bishop
G4 and just pin the Knight and this is
theoretically not supposed to be that
much of a big deal for white position is
a balanced
so Lego goes for H3 takes away that move
and prepares D4 and of course this is
one of the big main lines of the Spanish
97 97 isn't really popular these days
but has been a line played by prominent
players in the past
D4 Bishop F6 so Black's main plan is to
over defend the E5 Pawn however that
comes at a price of the night on D7
being rather awkward because it does not
really do too much apart from defending
that square
now this Knight on D7 apart from being
bad it also blocks off that Bishop on CA
now if you've been watching the magma
store recently you may have noticed that
many players at that top level actually
kind of try to force their opponents to
get a bishop like that because it can't
really contribute too much to the game
and oftentimes black will have to waste
time
to actually
get it to a better spot
all right so this might be the first
time you see this position
what do you think
would make
some sense
as whites to play here
so very unusual play by black
but by in itself that doesn't mean that
it's necessarily bad unusual could be
good
however we know some basic Spanish
principles and we may actually be able
to use them
Bishop E3 makes sense and in fact that
responds to Black's only idea of
pressing the D4 Pawn right now my D2
does not work for that very reason
because you could go after that
G4 well there is actually a rule of
thumb and that's the rule of the
Guardian pawns you are not supposed to
move Pawns in front of your king h-bond
sometimes you can but pushing the pawn
straight in front of your king is
something frowned upon on the top level
of Chess because it can devastatingly
weaken your king
so don't don't touch that Bond it's
there to defend your king
there's a reason they're called The
Guardian Palms
so there is a principle in the Spanish
where you know that there's some
weaknesses in the position you can go
after and that is the B5 and a sixth
month that is correct E4 is the typical
idea and it also indirectly presses the
A8 Rook
so it not only puts pressure on the weak
pawn it also creates some tactical
threats so naturally leco opts for that
move
ever is a great move it's a typical one
on the other hand I see nothing wrong
with Bishop to E3 that's definitely a
move that you can consider here A4
Knight A5 Bishop C2 now on principle you
might get already somewhat suspicious of
Black's play
even though black often plays this way
the Knight is under REM and it's not
looking good there and this other night
on D7 don't look good either
so black is already getting into some
hot Waters
Bishop B7
D5 now there is an old rule whenever
Black Goes Bishop to B7
D5 is a great move because it basically
mummifies the bishop on B7 and it really
is unable to exert any sort of pressure
the only way that black can try to
somehow do a Houdini Act is to go with
C6 however if you move that pawn that
square on D6 is going to get loose and
the D Pawn may just fall
a b mine itself isn't going to change
anything because the Rook is defending
the A5 Knight
White Knight A5 well black is trying to
avoid this 8xb5 threat and also freeing
the C Pawn for some further action
Bishop B7
D5 Bishop E7 so Pinter is making sure
that the D Pawn is over protected
so let's take a look at this position
so far very logical play by leco
and logical play by chat all props to
chat well done
what can we do here
how can we continue on with our plans
it's all about understanding concepts
regardless of your level
and it's the same thing here as well
Queen E2 makes sense
you can go Knight D2 Knight F1 Knight G3
Queen E2
but I'll give you a little bit of a hint
here
once you embark on a plan you should
always try to go through with it make
sure you follow it up because if you
don't do it that's when you can't really
learn from your own play because you're
combining too many ideas at the same
time
and just to jog your memory we were
trying to undermine the a6b5 upon chain
so we should follow up with that
in fact Lego
goes Knight A3
not your usual move
by today's standard a typical move at
that but he follows the rule of not
moving the queen out too early
therefore the early morning rule you
don't want to wake her up too early she
might get grumpy on you
now Queenie to Queen D3 the issue is
that if you move it early you actually
just find yourself in trouble
it's going to become an easier Target
that's why most of the grand Masters and
super Grand masters of our time wait
with that and rather facilitate
development for the light pieces may it
be Knight to D2 Knight F1 Knight G3 or
Knight to A3 now Knight D3 looks like a
weird move however it has its point
it keeps on piling on the B5 Pawn make
sure that the Pentair is busy defending
it and also keeps this diag open for the
bishop
because whenever you go on id2 you'll
have to patiently wait for that Knight
to move away and then you can double up
the dark squared one over there so 93 C6
B4 Knight C4
and uh so far so good laco has been
following his plan very beautifully
however this is the time for a reckoning
what should we do now
and just a disclaimer
this is more of a strategical position
so don't expect like fireworks and
Checkmate even though it does happen in
the Spanish but this is more of the
strategical side of Chess in fact the
whole variation the whole Spanish
variation is all about maneuvering and
slow playing the game
it's not your typical Sicilian where
it's just pushing pawns and then just
mating
no this is the old good old Cafe La
Reagans we're gonna shuffle a little bit
and maybe we'll do a little dance if we
win if we don't win we don't do it do no
dances
so if you can get or create a weakness
and Pinterest position that's already
going to be a win
very good
very good Paul
captures and capturing on C6
and I really like Lego's move ordering
um we don't really talk about that a ton
but it's very important because if you
take on T6 there are occasions where
they can capture a piece instead however
Knight takes C4 is a strong move here
because it actually forces uh Pinter's
head he has to capture back D takes
takes and now we have to take a look at
this position and what Lego achieved he
actually got a majority on the queen
side so that is already a plus Lego has
a hope to create a past pawn and that
can convert into an advantage apart from
that there is a C4 upon weakness in the
position so he has a majority a C4 upon
weakness and another weakness on D6 and
that means that Lego is already making
some Headway
Knight D2 D5 and D5 even though feels
like the right move it creates more
weaknesses
and the fact that this bishop on D5 is
undefended so this was sort of the
strategical part
and once your opponent pieces become
loose basically pieces that don't have
anyone guarding them
that's the moment when tactics starts to
work so Knight F3
immediately double attacking on E5 and
D5 and that's actually the beauty of the
game
that he can actually do double attacks
but you can only start having double
attacks once your position
is in a good standing or in other words
you're better
so this one is practically forcing uh
Pentair to capture on F3 but now you
already get the bishop pair too so lake
is sort of accumulating the advantages
now
Queen C7 A5 fixing that weakness
very beautiful strategic play
King h8 Bishop A4
pressing that night then sort of
pinpointing that the E Pawn is still
very weak Rook C8 Queen D5 direct play
on the Knight on D7 Rook d8 Queen C6 he
says well
you have problems on E5 you've got
problems on C4 you'll have problems on
A6 I'm ready to liquidate into a
queenless end game
takes Knight B8
F5 F5 is a desperation but Pinter still
makes a very good choice here he says
well if I wait around
slowly my position is going to collapse
so I may as well just Muddy Waters
thanks should have six Rook takes F5 but
Lego doesn't mind he takes it he takes
the challenge
rookie eight
Rook takes F6 so this is the other part
of the story even though Lego is not
very well known for making tactical
decisions
in some cases he is more than willing to
go that extra mile and be more Tactical
do you want checked G ticks and now it
all seems to fall apart right because
Lakers Rook on A1 is pinned by that Rook
on the E1 Square so the big question is
if there is some way for us to untangle
as Peter laco
Bishop G5 exactly a beautiful little
tactical shot by leco it doesn't really
matter if you take on A1 I have Bishop
takes F6
and I will win your Rook
goes here and if you take here I just
capture here I capture and because my
Bishops are so strong and in this Knight
is just too passive
white has just an overwhelming position
rookie six rookie one
so now it's a Cascade of tactics in this
position
Rook D6 take six Bishop F4 so light code
does not mind the trades his position is
superior he has the better pieces Knight
D7
Bishop D5 Rook E2 Bishop C4 Oh No rookie
four oh no there goes the bishop
but did leiko have something in mind in
this case
or is he just going to resign
to quote classics
pause
nanchamp
it looks like it's game over
Bishop D3
Bishop D3 Rook takes F4 and now the
unbelievable thing happens King to G3
and black is up a whole Rook but it's
captured on the middle of the board
can't go anywhere
anywhere you go
anywhere you try to go I follow
in every step you take every move you
make
I'm going to capture you
so Knight E5 takes
King E4 and what is most important in a
pawn ending well it's King activity and
a knight is pretty much helpless as Lego
King's
marches in to the center
activating it and it's game over a
beautiful display of positional
understanding and tactical Promise by
the we're a championship
Challenger beautiful game by Laker but I
wanted to show a game that his student
Vincent played who actually became 2700
just recently so let's take a look at
this one where Vincent kymer is facing
arcade naidich
who's a strong player in his own right
and not surprisingly they opt for a very
very tactical and aggressive game this
is the King's Indian so we are expected
a fight B6 Knight F3 C6 and C6 is sort
of a choice just to avoid Theory
Castle I mean castles is what I would
expect it goes for E4
A6
castles B5
and whenever you think about Vincent you
sort of expect the same thing that I
told you about leco very subtle
positional
doesn't really want uh
aggression necessarily however their
cases when he takes his chances
what do you think we can do in this case
in this position
all right
yeah no one does welcome in Ken West hey
hello how are you feeling good so in
this position
black slow played on this side of the
board
and really the question is if Vincent
should go aggressive
obviously he should
but if he does
how could he do it
yeah vitamin exactly
E5 indeed E5 is a very very strong move
and it just shows that even though
Vincent
follows more of the principled
slow-moving chess
if time comes he goes for the most
principled and aggressive move in the
position here
it's actually very strong because it
opens up this long diagonal and even
though some of his pieces are solidly
placed it is still looking kind of dire
for black immediately
so black decides to go on Knight E8
C5
another very very strong move by Vincent
fixing the weakness on C6
Bishop G4
C ticks he takes Bishop F4
all very principled following
the logic here making sure this Rook
will be able to join the attack later on
detects detects Knight D7
and uh Vincent's next move is quite
beautiful
because it feels that
Mac is sort of having some fun
and some pressure because there is this
pin on the queen on D1 and also the E5
Pawn is sort of feeling loose now
however Vincent actually finds a
solution very much reminiscent of uh
laco's display where it says uh Pinter
Knight E2 now 92 is a little bit too
solid
what we're looking for uh
here as white is something more drastic
surprising but more drastic
by all means
A4 so we have to keep in mind that our
E5 Pawn is under a heavy fire
so if for
by all intents and purposes is
aggressive which is good but you want to
and you should actually act in the
center
see Yakuza
E6
E6 which looks like something out of a
different planet you should just see
can vest Grandmaster canvas is astounded
E6 is actually a beautiful beautiful
Pawn sacrifice
because it is sort of made on positional
grounds it
isn't that he's winning and he's going
to get material back
but here black captured back with the
pawn but if Bishop takes the nearest
Knight to D4
and of course you must take care but
then it's just toast because you're dead
on the dark squares
and if you don't I'm just going to take
on C6 and with this garage sale of
pieces you are unlikely to survive
so E6 is a beautiful move sort of uh
loosening up Black's position
and getting rid of a Target that night
each was after
F takes E6
H3 Bishop H5 and here again Vincent
plays a beautiful one
which is great and also more of a
strategic move
because black is still putting up some
pressure
note the pen and know that maybe the
long run E5 could be an idea
so kymer's next move is going to
actually
just solve that problem
if you go Queen to B3 then there is
Knight C5 jump so that actually doesn't
really work that well
so he plays the very funny looking Queen
E1 which is the most awkward looking
move that you could make but here it's
actually very good not only do you step
out of this spin you're also getting
this Rook involved
and you're targeting the E6 Pawn
and what Vincent is doing right now
is sort of keeping Knight ditches pieces
back on the 7th and 8th and not giving
him extra tampies
that's why Queen E1 is such a great move
because it creates a threat avoid some
threats of blacks and it kind of
prepares this Rook to get developed note
that everything white did was sort of
and in some ways developing his piece
captures captures on E6
Bishop F3
G5 Rook D1
and it almost works for black because
these Bishops like Bishop can't move
because the F3 Bishop is hanging but
tactics actually comes and helps camera
GF Rook takes Queen F6
all right the big question time
should we trade the ladies or not
now
in order to make a good judgment call
you should always count them at pieces
that's the most important thing here
if you don't count them pieces you don't
know what you're missing
so Cruiser is saying not if we attack
it's not always about attacks it's
always about material
it's not that you decide okay I'm going
to attack it's about the demands of the
position and I think that's a big and
Grave misunderstanding people decide oh
I've been attacking for like 15 moves
it must be a mating attack it's not how
it's done if the position that depends
and it wants you to go and slow play it
you may as well slow play it
he slow plays it he says well according
to my humble count I've got an extra
Pawn
you got an extra Pawn trees are good
take sticks Rook C8 Bishop B7 he's
gaining a little bit of time
my knight each is desperately looking
for some counter play
look C7 do we trade
do we trade
we don't trade just yet we just double
The Rook
so a lot of times it's difficult to tell
what you ought to be looking for
but in this case the best idea you may
want to do is a can I trade is that
beneficial to my position or can I
strengthen my position
now Rook D1 in this case is pretty good
because it strengthens the position and
it keeps black snide back on E8
take sticks B4 now note if you take here
you can capture here first
takes and I'm up an extra palm and
that's good enough
at least on Grand Master levels
before Knight A4
so once you get the extra material your
goal is to over defend your position
Knight A4 actually makes sure the B2 is
well guarded even this move of Rook fd1
made sure that all of White's pieces are
well defended and again again the
important thing G3 Pawn is weak while
it's only weak if you can attack it you
can't attack it so it's not really that
weak
A5 in G2 and yeah that tractor on D7 is
steamrolling the seventh rank
actually putting a lot of pressure on
black position ticks takes
Knight F6 Rook D2
now this actually sort of resembles uh
his coach his trainers uh play just
making sure everything's over defended I
have the advantage I don't have to go
for one more pawn and just let you get
some counter play
H5 Knight C5 now this Knight wasn't
doing anything anymore so it comes
closer and it may actually join The Fray
on the king side
rookie 8 that actually cuts that off
Bishop F3
so as he can't jump around there he's
actually setting up ideas of Knight B7
as well H4 G4
keeps the healthy extra pawn and if you
can actually set up a protected path
Pawn you should and so does Vincent
rookie five check Knight D3 again
doesn't go for adventures also by now
The Rook was defending it
goes Knight D3 no D6
Rook D7 Bishop E4 check
and again notice that yes he goes for
more strategy but
in this case he still uses some tactics
of course this bishop is taboo because I
just captured on B sub
King H6
Rook A6 now he goes after that and again
uses the fact that the Knight cannot
capture
of D4 Bishop F5 over the family so he's
not trying to abuse these tactics he's
trying to incrementally improve his
position with every little step three
Bishop E4
or B5 of course he'd be okay with the
trade now because the king comes closer
to the center
will be five Bishop C6 and again the
Knight is denying some crucial squares
and so is the Rook
have to move captures check
check game is technically over
G5 but still note that he is making sure
that there are no counter play for black
G5 is actually creating a little safe
space for the king in case of a rook E3
check
ing G4
King F5 everything well guarded and now
the king is in trouble
will be five
of D5 in G4 takes check
ing out five King G6
Knight D5 the Knight is coming
okay five King G6 again tactics
is mate
in another move
check Knight F6 and here black resigned
because King h8 there is made here
and if you go King f8
is
so I really hope you enjoyed this one on
how to become a grand master
between this players so we've been
talking about Lego who is the coach and
Vincent keimer who is his pupil and
actually hit 2700 just recently so I
really hope you enjoyed your time over
here we looked at that
um I am going to sign off here
hope to see you guys again in the future
thank you so much for watching and being
here
and we'll be on Twitch later yes
[Music]